quatre jours de colloque scientifique
une vingtaine de publications mais qu'en
sortira-t-il pour le quotidien des
martiniquais plusieurs axes de travail
sont retenus par les autorités
la première et la plus importante
réduire l'exposition de la population
pour cela les modalités de l'objectif
zéro chlordécone fixé par le président
de la république reste encore bien flou
on nous a non seulement un renforcement
des contrôles
une chose est sûre les limites maximales
de résidus augmenté dans la viande et la
volaille devrait être rabaissée on va
même ré évaluer la toxicité général du
chlordécone dans le sang va d'abord
fixer une valeur critique d'imprégnation
c'est à dire en gros là la concentration
sanguine limite au dessus duquel on
aurait un sur risque
et puis à partir de là estimé quelle est
la quantité maximale que vous pouvez
ingérés par alimentation % que pour
éviter tout risque sur la santé
donc ça c'est un travail qui va se
dérouler au cours des deux prochaines
années et qui s'appuie vraiment sûr
finalement les nouvelles études et en
particulier celles qui viennent d'être
présentés pendant ce colloque les doses
autorisées de chlordécone pourrait donc
baisser pour tous les aliments d'ici
deux ans le colloque a confirmé le
danger du pesticide pour les foetus un
programme spécifique pour les femmes
enceintes sera développé nous allons
lancer celle agences régionales de santé
qui va le faire dans les toutes
prochaines semaines avant la fin de
l'année un programme qui sera spécifique
aux femmes enceintes
il implique tous les professionnels de
santé y compris ceux de la protection
maternelle et infantile et l'idée c'est
comment on assiste lapin enceinte on lui
donne les meilleurs conseils possibles
sur son alimentation pour réduire son
exposition au chlordécone
autre annonce le programme jaffa qui
aident les particuliers à faire tester
leur sol et à développer des pratiques
de culture sans danger sera renforcée à
1000 actions par an c'est du côté de la
pêche qu'il faudra ensuite dit et les
nouveautés mais la préfecture souhaite
d'abord une concertation avec les
professionnels